ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby-doo this crap you know all
this is kind of your mess i know a
couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please
please scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man it's
their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
so don't has to be another wind there
isn't
there a danger to our universe
you're not going to take this away from
me
peter
you're struggling
damn
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
exclusively in movie theaters